sal was running around with your
megaphone well let me talk to you about
that
i uh talked to sal about it sal was
running around here when he had a bad
cold
using my megaphone in the halls coughing
all over her house
i will use clorox uh things you should
be scared this is a deal breaker for me
i do not want i got to be able to trust
the guys i work with that they don't
touch my stuff
right i don't know what you're thinking
first of all i'm a kook about germs i'm
completely irrational
plus you had a cold now i just got a
cold maybe you gave me your [ __ ] call
i don't know i am just livid with you
i'm i'm beside myself
i don't even know i mean there aren't
even any words for me
it's not a joke i mean because
this job does mean everything to me and
lately a lot of stuff has been piling up
i don't want to piss you off and
i just used poor judgment why would you
listen
to the music why why would you touch my
mega i mean
like leave my i don't touch your stuff i
respect that it's yours richard and i
decided that it would be funny if we we
started going behind people shouting
with the megaphones like surprising them
fine get your own megaphone
don't touch my stuff you know what it is
man seriously
your illness about me and your love of
me or
it's past love it's obsession you
putting your hands on my megaphone
it's almost like you're holding me up to
your mouth like it's it's honestly
psychologically
you got to get past this dude you're
whacked out of your friggin skull
and you got to stay away from my stuff
it was just it was just
poor judgment it's not me i don't what
else are you doing are you going into my
office you're not touching stuff
oh i i hope you accept my apology as
sincerely i'm making a mistake i don't
because it's not a mistake there's no
such thing as a mistake like
this bad judgment you keep pointing to
why do you think it's going to get
better because i know never to touch any
of howard's things again
no you don't know anything until after
you've done it and we told you it was
wrong is there any time you couldn't
believe it was a [ __ ] lawyer
but she's right i know not to touch this
[ __ ] robin what is this
if you don't have judgment dude it
doesn't now you know
there's got to come a time where you
look at that megaphone
and say or whatever that's gonna happen
you go you know what
this ain't worth it i'm gonna you gotta
have some judgment right
the megaphone should have never happened
is what she's saying right when are you
gonna be able to read a situation and go
you know what [ __ ]
i gotta respect this guy's private space
this is a guy who gave me a job
and this is a guy i like and this is a
guy whose respect i want
this is a guy whose trust i want you can
trust that i'm not going to go into your
office and go through your personal
things
you can though but i don't want to the
only person i'll do that with his friend
right i don't respect his
personal spouse but you have to learn to
respect
mine right and can you is it fair to say
in a year and a half i i pretty much
have
it's not wow it's not fair to say that
because you just screwed up
right well and you probably have screwed
up before you probably died
i'm not shutting my mouth so just get
over it
it's not gonna happen you know what you
like you like it's not you're like that
little weasel behind the bully yeah yeah
i don't need you chiming in when i'm
trying to make a sincere apology
you're being mean we do a show you
should be the last person to talk about
piling on when somebody's getting
crappy i'm just asking a politely to be
quiet
you didn't ask politely at all so stop
that whatever
all right howard i know leave my things
alone and um i just want robin's things
alone
leave robin alone all right you could
screw with benji i don't care